The most common thing that you do in the
rules, besides checking if the user is
the owner of the list, is to check
whether the user is shared on the list.
A prime example of this is the read
rule for the shoppingListitems.
So using the sharedWith table,
can you check if the current user
is shared on the shopping list?
So if you're talking about a shopping
list and you go over to userLists, and
you look at the details of shopping
list, you can see the owner's here.
But because we've de-normalized some
stuff, there are kind of parts of
a shopping list which are located
to different parts of the database.
One example being shoppingListitems,
and also sharedWith.
Both of these are associated
with a single shopping list.
So let's say we are looking at the items
for this shopping list, shopping list
K7J-8k, and remember that shopping list
owner is [INAUDIBLE] as shown here.
If I'm over here in shoppingListitems,
I could drill down and
I don't really see who the owner
of the shopping list is.
That's not stored here.
The owner of each of the items is stored
here but, not the owner of the entire
shopping list,
which is important for some checks.
And this leads to kind of long and
difficult to read rules for
shoppingListitems when I
want to say something like
the owner the shopping
list can read these items.
So can you think of a better solution
for getting the order of a shopping list
and using it in the rules for
a shoppingListitems and sharedWith?
Maybe you could draw some inspiration
from the UND mapping note that
you just created.
I'll go ahead and
send a respect right now.